[Music]
[Music]
I'm a big fan of the way you make your
movies you know the lengths you go to
you the risks you take to entertain the
audience so what but what drives you the
most like you know when you when you're
kind of putting your life on the line in
some cases especially in this movie
multiple sequences what drives you to do
that when you don't have to the audience
I think I think of those people there on
opening weekend and I want to I think of
I want to thrill them I want them to
have the greatest time you know whatever
it's like if I'm making them sit on the
edge of their seat or whatever it is
whatever film that I'm making I can't do
anything halfway I I feel truly like in
my core of that it's a privilege what I
get to do
I love making movies and because I love
watching movies and to be able to
entertain people and that's what that's
what I think about that's what I think
about when I'm hanging from that
helicopter and it's freezing weather and
I've got to let go that rope
you know it's exhilarating I enjoy it
you know don't get me wrong it's
something that is it's it's it's also
can be quite you know it's an adrenaline
rush it's nerve-wracking at times very
and stressful but I do am thinking about
that audience I'm thinking about that
shot and and thinking about what what
it's going to be like on the big screen
for them and that's what I want and when
I make a film I'm not thinking about
movies in terms of opening weekend or
that I'm trying to make it in a classic
manner or give it the highest highest
level of quality that it's something
that could be looked at hopefully five
or 10 years from now you know that you
know those movies that you and I look at
that were made before that we can't help
ourselves but you know we're there it's
like I just I want that experience again
and and that's what I hope to give to an
audience that's what I want
you know one of my favorite scenes
audience is gonna walk out there to talk
about the skydiving the car true through
power is the helicopter my personal
favorite is the bathroom I think it's
just you know it not only is it great
because it's Ethan hunts very vulnerable
in that scene but it's also badass brawl
you know like talk to me about that
scene was it challenging to shoot is it
hard to get your ass kicked a little bit
oh it's it's not listen he kicking ass
and getting your ass kicked his heart
they both ways all of us
none of us walked away from that scene
going we were all limping trust me it
was and none of us would admit it by the
way not one of us would ever admit it
but it's it was a bone bruising scene to
shoot and you know McHugh and I talked
about it just even structurally coming
up with how that fight unfolds was very
important the way it did not only just
for an entertainment factor but in terms
of how it affects yeah plot that would
effects the plot and and and also the
the emotion and dynamic of the
characters when they see it you know in
the end of the movie but it's just so
much fun I mean we were just saying like
this has to happen in this way this has
to happen this way and we talked about
we wanted shots where let's hang on
these shots as long as possible like the
only thing that is dictating the cut is
just geography it is is points of story
not we're not cutting because we're
trying to fake a punch we're not we're
cutting because of story not because we
don't have it on camera so when you're
shooting something like that it means
you you know in order to be able to do
that you have to get it right in every
take you have to get those takes so that
they're playing long enough so that
we're able to make the least amount of
cuts so that when the audience is going
through it you want I want to invest the
audience not just in all that big action
they've got to invest in the character
and the emotional journey so that
they're feeling those blows you know for
both from both me and Henry you feel
that [ __ ] good I'm so happy I am so
happy to hear that
because that's what we wanted you to
talk about lingering on scenes when
you're climbing up the helicopter is
another one of my favorite moments
because that's what separates these
movies from other movies in another
movie that's a wide shot if the stunt
double he climbs up really fast
they shared a stage yeah the camera
right there and in real time it's just
watching you just kind of get up there
get that helicopter that pulls back and
it's just watching and I'm just climbing
up yeah it was that a hard heart the
first person asked me climbing up that
rope that was hard it was it was cold
you know that's a long rope climb did
you master the rope climb in gym class
like were you that was that no I was I
you know it's it's but it's never easy
it's not like the rope climbs ever no
one's like oh I can do this easy it's a
rope climb man and it's it's hard you
know so and it was exhausting doing that
and I'm also training for the helicopter
at that point we shot Paris already and
I just remember that day I was just and
I was I had to train you know climbs up
there so that I could make the whole
climb and I had to do it several times
not now when I get to the top you see me
hanging on to the thing and I'm
breathing heavy that is literally gone
come on guys you know please then now I
have to drop again you know that was
intense
Ethan where are you I'm in a helicopter
but you can fly a helicopter you know we
love talking about the running that you
do in movies so much so that we sat down
and estimated how many steps you've run
in all your movies came out to about
24,000 or like four and a half miles is
that right what do you think is that
what you think that's under estimating
it or I don't know man I think that's
pretty cool hey that's really cool but
what's you put in movies though
sometimes I'll have to do that sprint 50
times to get that one to get that one
take so it takes take after take to get
those you know that's one of those
things I'm supposed to have that level
of impact hitting the wall I just put my
foot out try to soften the impact I knew
instantly it was broken yeah this one
the ankles the ankles broken it's it's
I'm about 11 to 12 weeks into a broken
ankle at that point Wow yeah was that
kind of I mean you do all these big
stunts but that's got to be one of the
harder things at youth that hurt I mean
that yeah I mean there's stuff that I
break or you sprain or your bone bruise
and stuff like that I mean you're when
you're making these movies you're just
trying to pace your body through it and
definitely when you finish it it's you
know you need recovery time just like an
athlete in the offseason I don't really
get an offseason you know the way that I
work but but I really have to pay
attention to it that break was okay was
10 to 12 hours of rehab a day even when
I was sprinting in the movie when you
see it I couldn't walk for days
afterwards I guy I would do those
Sprint's and then then I'm basically you
know head to day and I would sit on set
and a on a little box and get up do my
lines and then sit down again you know
because it was just too painful
out of my way hunt Walker we got a
problem there's a storm when we need to
enough talk I'll see my parents
[Music]
no I was just gonna ask you about the
longevity of the series and whether or
not these movies and when you're
finished with them or if you're open to
like James Bond defying it and having
other people play yeah I mean it would
be interesting to see what happens to
see what an audience you know I I would
never ask anyone I've the kind of stuff
that I've done has been things that I've
cultivated and to have someone to say
you have to do this that's that's like
now I don't know if I could ask anyone
to do that even if they would want to do
it and people think they want to do it
but once they start kind of doing it
they realize how challenging it is and
it's it's also look it's I've been doing
this since I was a little kid doing
stuff like this and I've been really
working on a1 systems on how to make it
so that you can actually survive these
things and create those so it's
something that of course my whole idea
was that the franchise would always go
on but I just you know maybe nice you
know I hope you bake like seven more I
said you never know you be bullied and
then I'll be like okay
thank you so much favorite action thank
you so much
[Music]
you